A new fish has been discovered off the coast of Indonesia.
And besides being beautiful, it has a unique way of moving through the water.
Let's take a look.
The University of Washington scientist, who this month officially described...
...this new species of fish, chose to call it Histiophryne psychedelica...
...or H. psychedelica for its orange and brown stripes.
H. psychedelica was first spotted in the harbor of Ambon Island in Indonesia in January 2008.
It took more than a year of testing by the university's Professor Ted Pietsch...
...to establish that it was indeed unique.
DNA work revealed that the fish is of the genus Histiophryne along with two other species,...
...although its two cousins are far less spectacular in appearance.
The genus is one of about a dozen in the family commonly known as frogfish.
Despite its showy appearance, H. psychedelica is shy and secretive...
...and Professor Pietsch says, its reluctance to show off...
...may explain why it has managed to stay hidden for so long.